if you could travel back and change one
thing help you at a time machine
yeah that'd be I do have a time machine
computer turn on the time machine time
machine is on let's cut to a wide shot
oh all right computer turn off time
machine hello
any time now computer turn off time
machine there we go all right that's the
time machine that's all it does
it's just lights up all right so if I
had a time machine if I go back and
change one thing what would it be I
don't know that I don't know that I
would cuz that's I've had a lot of time
thinking about this question I've
thought about this for months because I
built a time machine art project at
Burning Man and that was the question
that I wanted everyone else to ask
right like what is this fantasy of
time-travel why is it that we fantasize
about seeing into the future and
preventing certain catastrophes or maybe
planning out some sort of win investment
or whatever like seeing into the future
and just scoring big or looking back in
the past and changing some of these hard
grievances that you know these memories
that have like weighed down on us right
those things you know those are the
things that shape you so those the past
trauma it kind of makes you who you are
so if you were to take away those things
would you still be you I don't know
that's that's a larger question I asked
but I the interesting thing is that I
did leave inside the time machine art
project that we built we left little
pieces of paper for people to write down
where we asked this question so we had
about 200 responses and it was
incredible I mean the amount of
responses that we got that were like
people for the most
part you know they wanted to spend more
time they wish they spent more time with
their kids or they wish they didn't they
wish they spoke to their father and
buried the hatchet before he got sick
right so like all like they had all
these these things that were so valuable
and so meaningful and important none of
them were oh I wish I have s today Apple
in 1980 you know like it was all
relationships and personal stuff so I
don't know if you've seen that like the
dying wishes of people with you know
cancer whatever on their on their
deathbed and they're living back there
regrets and whatever almost all of their
answers are the same and it's all I wish
I spent more time with my family
which hadn't worked so hard which I you
know what I mean it's all personal
relationships I think that's the same
thing that's probably my answer how did
you feel when people left these
responses for you like were you sort of
overwhelmed that they trusted the
process enough or I mean they didn't
well I mean it was a sense of autonomy
so these people were leaving their
answers without any other information so
I felt like where there was a sense of
privacy so they were they no one was
going to judge them so they were
incredibly private with their responses
and I felt I felt really lucky in fact
at first I wanted to include their
responses or read them off in my my
video that I did about it but then I
felt like that might have been a
betrayal so I kept them for myself I
still have them and I don't know if I'll
make something from them one day or you
know I read them from time to time but I
mean there's some powerful stuff in
there because it's on paper right so
there's no Wi-Fi there's no way anybody
can come and hack in and see any answers
yeah you just it was a it was a little
mail drop box so you know it was great I
mean there's also a couple of dick pics
in there as well well that's great well
dick drawings yeah I've probably only
one person I didn't he didn't numerous
times there's like three or four like
Wow and he got better at each one you
know you got a bunch of artists and
they're bored
I forget those those are great
you